if you're watching the Game Awards you
will have seen that Microsoft has
officially revealed the next Xbox Peter
Brown managing editor at GameSpot had
the opportunity to meet with Phil
Spencer and Jason Ronald to talk about
this new Xbox and now he's gonna relay
some of the information that he learned
there to us sent to you Peter why is
this Xbox called I'm not gonna beat
around the bush because everyone's
pretty much seen it by now it is a tower
it has a square footprint and it is a
tall monolith and that said it can also
be put on its side so you don't have to
keep it upright it's actually how Phil
Spencer has his at home is on its side
and it's called the Xbox series X what
was their reasoning behind calling it
that and what do you think it means for
the future of Xbox consoles going
forward I could speculate forever right
I think there are a lot of rumors out
there right now about there being two
different versions of whatever the next
Xbox is what Phil Spencer said was that
when they named a console right they
always try to do it around what it
represents what's it gonna do so if I
think about the names series X the title
series implies that there could be
others right because it's a distinction
and X as we know is the moniker for the
most powerful version of the Xbox one
that's available today they did not make
any mention of this or any confirmation
a purely speculation on my part but it
seems to me that the rumors out there
could be true and that we could see
another Xbox that could be called Xbox
series yes perhaps I mean it wouldn't be
a surprise given that following the from
the 360 onwards they have always
revealed and released a revised version
of that console yeah it's also worth
pointing out too that like the console
is one piece of the thing X cloud is
also a huge pieces experience so even if
let's say I think the current rumors are
that the Xbox or the the lesser version
of the new Xbox like based on the rumors
alone is going to be somewhere close to
the Xbox one X right now right and I
think a lot of that in order to bring
parity to the experience is going to the
heavy liftings gonna be done by X cloud
right so going back to the actual visual
signs that you saw
an image of video of the console same
one everyone else the same one that
everyone else saw so did they speak
about the kind of a decision to go for a
towel format or what what was the
thinking behind that it's very unusual
for a console traditionally as we know
them to be they're always flat what's
the deal here Phil Spencer said that
they wanted to approach this console to
be a performance leader that that's a
position that they liked to have in the
industry like when we think about the
Xbox one acts over the ps4 Pro for
example so he said that he basically
went to the engineering teams and said
these are the specs these are the things
we want to reach for and I want you to
build a system that can achieve that
rather than saying here's what we want
it to look like make the tech fit in
there or say it has to fit these
dimensions for whatever reason make it
work so it really really sounds like
this was born out of the engineering
know how to accomplish the goals that
they set out for which includes a lot of
things right and like it's still
aesthetically quite pleasing right it's
just got more of an industrial design to
it personally I am in love with the
design just because it's so simple it's
a black tower again I use the word
monolith because it's that's just what I
think of when I see it it's got a vents
on the top with sort of largest looking
circles and a green concave thing
beneath it and that's where the only fan
in the system is housed right and
through that one fan alone despite the
console being four times as powerful as
X Spencer and Ronald were telling me
that it is just as loud slash quiet as
the Xbox one X currently so huge power
increase and the form factor allows them
to do that I'm sure with some other
things as well but the form factor helps
them achieve that without making the the
audio signature too loud because they
just want this thing to sort of be there
but not take away from the experience of
the game because it's blowing fans
really loudly seems like a one small
step closer to the PC kind of odd
Jeff Stowell yeah I wish I had more time
to talk to them about that I only had
about 10 minutes for questions but it
you know the design definitely evokes
that of a traditional PC but I think
when you also think about the sort of
tech specs and the claims that they're
making just in my own head I know there
are still a ton of reasons for PC gaming
so I don't want to suggest that I think
PC gaming is going to become irrelevant
but as you say it's like one step
towards creating just a or breaking down
the disparity between things like
consoles and PCs in terms of what's the
most powerful because I think when you
start to talk 8k when you started to
talk 120 frames per second on TVs well
yeah at that point you know what is a PC
other than a place for open platforms
for people to publish games right so
tell us about the controller yes we've
got this new look it looks a lot like
this controller and I backed it looks
almost identical from the video as most
people saw one of the big changes is in
the middle there is a share button right
so that will go and to do what you know
you see happening already on like
PlayStation right share screenshots
share gameplay things like that they did
say that the controller was reduced in
size just a little bit they quoted a
very high percentage of the current
controller fitting the hands of like
most of the people around the world
based on their studies and the new one
is supposed to just raise that bar just
a little bit higher I was told I mean
this is getting into minutia but the
sort of angle here is more rounded off
and it actually bleeds into the handles
so rather than have this cliff you just
have a more smooth ergonomic I suppose
controller I still have not hold it
myself again this is the old one they
say it'll be roughly the same size and
because I think a lot of us and I'm sure
people are gonna already be opening in
Photoshop and drawing lines and stuff
they showed the controller next to the
new system right so it's effectively
roughly as wide as the controller so as
wide as it is deep if it's got that
square footprint and it looked about
three times as tall so I'm not a huge
box right like it definitely looks like
something that's not quite a console but
it's not as big as a PC certainly
the actual controller is it designed
specifically to function just with that
iteration of the xbox a series X or can
it be used in previous consoles they've
talked previously about obviously they
have the elite controller which is an
expensive machine and they've said in
the past that they want to ensure that
people who own that can continue to use
that is that the case for this new
console - absolutely and I think it's
actually more than just the series -
that's going to work on the new system
they were saying that all your Xbox one
controllers are gonna work ok
likewise the new controller for series X
I still I'm still trying to wrap my head
around the difference between Xbox one X
and series X it's a tough it's gonna be
tough for SEO but yes the new controller
will work on Xbox one and on your PC as
well so you can take it wherever you
take your Xbox controller - ok and in
terms of games yeah we know that halo
infinite we know we know there's a bunch
of here games in production so Microsoft
recently went on the acquisition spree
of acquiring a bunch of studios and at
least one of those studios is you know
the project is bearing fruit for the
series ex-ninja theory is working on a
new game they are and it is send you as
saga el blade - ok so if you saw the
reveal of the console you probably also
saw the reveal of this game maybe you
heard maybe you didn't while watching
but everything they've shown in that
reveal is running in engine and I caveat
everything I'm about to say with that
yes these were you know cutscenes that
were probably meticulously made to you
know reach the fidelity that they have
and Spencer and Ronald both stress to me
that this game is taking advantage of
everything the Xbox one X could be like
that's what this is meant to do it looks
amazing
I was I was just kind of it was it was
that moment where I'm you know we always
talked about with each new console
generation especially now when we're
approaching things like 4k where it's
like you know what point are we gonna
level off where graphics sort of stop
mattering so much I'm not gonna say that
we're there yet because I'm sure there
are things that could be improved that
I'm not even thinking of but my god dude
I was looking at this and it just it
looked like I was watching just a CG
pre-rendered movies
it looks so incredible and a large part
of that has to do with rate racing as
well yeah we didn't we couldn't get into
the nitty-gritty of it but we're some
rate racing support comes from a lot of
software side things the system is going
to be doing that with hardware specific
right and though I didn't really get to
experience this they were saying that
look great racing is good you know what
it is it is bounces light around a scene
it can calculate that better than other
methods so gate the lighting looks more
realistic your average scene looks more
realistic that also applies to audio
they can basically just track the audio
along those same vectors as they bounce
to do spatial audio through ray tracing
as well so sinuous saga just I mean it
looks it looks incredible it looks super
haunting and it's I mean if the
expression like this sort of extreme
moments of expression that came out in
that first game really spoke to you I
think like me you probably watched that
and just felt like I can't wait to see
what else is in store for send you
especially with some of the scenes they
showed do my risk of delving too deep
into the game itself was there any
indication of how far along that game
might be given that you know the
acquisition of ninja tear is fairly
recent does that mean this is just an
early or early version of the game or is
it something that they've been working
on prior to the acquisition so they when
I asked this question the discussion was
basically like well we've got a long
standing relationship with ninja theory
and by the time we approached them with
hey maybe we should work together become
partners that sort of thing this game
existed on their roadmap it didn't sound
like it was already in development in
terms of like okay we know what we're
making this for therefore we can define
our constraints this is our target date
I mean I don't think any of that was set
in stone probably until Microsoft
acquired them
yeah okay and some of the kind of other
things that people will no doubt want to
know about whether they disgust not is
like the service based stuff like Xbox
Live have they mentioned any sort of
indication of what's gonna happen with
that as they try as people transition to
the new console I was promised it was
gonna be seamless everything you
currently have access to on Xbox Live
including your achievements friends the
games you own is going to be available
on day one when this launches and when I
say games you own I mean backwards
compatibility with games that work on
Xbox one right now okay so that was a
lot of information was there any
indication on details such as release
date and price we still just have that
holiday 2020 window I didn't make any
new announcements regarding a specific
date or what this will cost well Spencer
is on record though saying that there I
forget the exact phrasing he used but
they're going to be in position when
this launches meaning that like the
price according to them based on where
they suspect the market to be is going
to be one that is fitting for the
console market right fitting for a
high-end console so I think if you kind
of imagine where something like the Xbox
one X was when it launched relative to
where we are then like yeah it'll it'll
probably be if I had to put on my Genie
cap and guess I would guess five hundred
dollars I feel like once you go above
that you're starting to ask a lot of
your customers but we'll see I have no
idea they didn't make any mention of
that purely just guessing on my part
because and I just want to guess right
now because I've seen this thing it
feels real and you mentioned earlier
that you also asked Phil Spencer about
the competitions all right yeah I think
quite he talked about it that way but I
know that classically he doesn't like to
think about console wars as a thing
because he doesn't feel like there's
meant to be a winner or a loser just
that people are supposed to lead each
other down new paths of innovation in a
sense which is a great way to put it and
and I don't know if I assume it's
genuine yeah you know they are
interested to see what Sony's gonna do
and obviously AMD their hardware partner
that's helped them on the GPU side and
the CPU side is also working with Sony
on the PlayStation 5 they're not sharing
info right they don't know exactly
what's going on with the PS 5 but they
you know like they did with
box 1x you see the pro kind of came out
roughly similar time like he was like
you know we've been in the industry long
enough that we kind of have a good sense
of where things stand and so but to
answer your question specifically is he
excited about it I think I got the
impression that he is sort of laser
focused right now on this on this new
launch but if anything I think he's and
he has to be I know but genuinely
excited about what this can do I like
the one big question mark I had which
was you're offering all this power and
that's great for the user but what does
that mean for developers like how are
they gonna keep up with these increasing
promises of games looking better like
doesn't that get more expensive what
happens for teams that are smaller and
in the middle side and you know he just
kind of believes that a good game is a
good game even if it's not like the most
impressive technical showcase and and
that the game wars is kind of like a
good reflection of that you get to see
the stuff that gets people excited and I
think even if you look at the portfolio
of people they've picked up right like
including the likes of Double Fine yeah
it makes sense like that every game is
gonna have to look so incredible but you
know the experience that's gonna come
with this console it's more than just
graphics just before we go you know it
also has to do with the faster loading
times with they hinted at trying games
from the cloud rather than buying them
so like if someone says hey you want to
try this game I'd be like sure I'll try
it out because I can write it's about
making the experience smoother for also
I think yeah the graphical stuff is
gonna be there but I'm also really
really interested to see just how
seamless using this console is gonna be
and alternatively because Sony has
promised very similar things what it's
gonna look like for them I think that's
gonna be one of the more unusual and
interesting talking points next year
right any indication of when they plan
to provide more information about the
series X said well we why are we doing
this that's something like the Game
Awards well you know for a lot of
reasons and then he also mentions III
2020 is gonna be a big one for us okay
so I think that's probably what we can
look forward to next we've already had
XO 19 happened a couple weeks back
reading into the new year I hate to say
it III is not far away
so get ready if for if anything more
Xbox Series X news yeah until then
people are gonna have to make do with
what we have on offer which we have
quite a bit yes
you have a feature written around the
actual piece the actual new console as
well as an interview and we've got a
bunch of breakout stories yeah so if you
want more information about the Xbox
Series X still confusing go to GameSpot
calm and in meantime you can find us on
- where I'm at - more H and P R is PC
Brown see you on the interwebs
you